just accept the first challenge that i
see
and uh wow that was a quick start first
move already
avenge 05 from russia
uh we got ourselves a london system my
opponent is playing very quickly
um but this is not considered the most
accurate way of playing as white because
queen b6
um especially then queen b3 c4
queen c2 bishop f5 is considered quite
comfortable for
for black and here here now that b3 has
been forced
uh that is forever going to be
a slight weakness in white's position
and that
means that although the
um um whitis
clearly has no particular problems it
means that i have
some prospects long term and i gotta say
as i've said before i feel like my
opponent is playing a bit too quickly
here
especially this last move rook ac1
um because there are some things to
consider here
uh especially bishop to a3 the obvious
response
would then be rook c2 but that would
lose to either
knight takes d4 or knight
b4 both moves attacking the rook and
basically trapping the rook and ensuring
that my rook from c8 will take the rook
on c2 later on
the question is whether i can gain it
anything from
bishop a3 rook d1 and so on
um knight takes e5 d takes e5
my knight is attacked so i don't want to
pawn
um probably i don't gain a whole lot but
i will do it anyway
um
bishop a3 a rook rook to d1 and i will
probably go queen to a5
continuing to hunt those pawns
uh rugby one is also natural
kind of kind of didn't consider that
now with queen a5 i feel like b4 could
be
um could be seriously inconvenient for
me
um okay let me uh try and reroute the
pieces instead
fish bait three that was a clear clear
case of
long long think wrong thing
because i ended up playing a subpar move
there
now i would at least open up the attack
on them
on the on the c file so although and
this
trade i'm very fairly happy with just
getting his knights away from
uh from e5 um and generally
trades here are pretty good for me
seeing as
i will be doing well in an ending
because of my superior pawn structure
um he does have a little trick here
which is rook to b3 or
i actually have a trick because rook b3
looks strong right
if it played rook b3 ab4
cb4 i cannot take on b4 with a bishop
because of a3 and that bishop cannot
move
because of pin on my queen um
but it turns out that i can put the
bishop on c1
instead only square that it has
but it's a good square and later on
i can potentially trade the bishop for
his knight and i will be
um i will be having a um
better pawn structure there think again
he should have gone
rp3 here um
because this trade is is very good for
me seeing as i have the more
compact pawn structure and his opponent
d4 is
um going to be weak until the day it
eventually falls
and his um um
his pawn on a2 may be weak as well
um yeah i do have the option of going
knight to h5
looking for some tricks like
bishop e3 rook takes e3 followed by
queen takes d2
or knight b3 rook takes b3 followed by
knight xf4
but after bishop g5 i don't see it f6
runs into queen takes g6 so i can't
really do that
so i'll do rook to c8 instead
often the most natural moves is just the
best
now rook c1 may be a bit of a threat so
i expect him to move his
knight either to f3 or to b3
probably probably f3 and then
i will almost certainly play knight e4
um explaining the fact that that square
is no longer
protected by um
by one of his um
bias knight uh i think maybe queen a6 is
not stupid here
i could have gone queen a7 forced to
trade then he goes
rook takes c8 rook takes c at knight f3
and my queen may not be doing all that
much on
on a7 it feels like it's a bit more
active on a6
and it also um
opens up the possibility of playing um
bishop to d6 later on uh once again
trading trading pieces should be good
for me seeing as i have
the better pawn structure and therefore
better prospects in the
and the ending uh also the
uh one advantage of putting the queen in
a6 is that i protect the c8 square so
now i can
i can just kick his queen away uh
my opponent is playing well though um i
think he's a little bit worse
but it's not a lot and
that's not a bad position to be in at
this point i may have a threat here
which
you think you missed um
knight c3 and now 92 is a very
strong threat uh picking up his bishop
if he moves the bishop i will go
knight to e2 and then i will play the
bishop to d6
with check and i will take on d4 with
the knight
opening an attack up from the queen to
a6
attacking f1 uh his rook there and
as far as i can see
i'm oh rook c1 is maybe possible now i'm
sorry rook e1
if 92 um
92 he will take and then take the bishop
on a3
so that is probably the only way not to
lose
material immediately uh i do think
however
after um rook to
e1 bishop to f8
i will win a pawn because i'm
threatening both
knight to e2 and taking the pawn on a2
so first tangible
result of um of the little pressure i've
had here is
is the wind of a pawn and
[Music]
that is nothing to to sneeze at i
believe
um yeah we trade
and now i should eventually
uh probably not know c3 because of rook
c1
now i should eventually be able to uh to
convert
happy to play f6 taking control over
both the squares his knight could
possibly jump to
and um yeah
later on i will probably knight d3
here trying to reroute that knight
um bishop b4
trying to make at least pseudo
active moves at some point i have to
speed up but for the moment
looks like he's doing worse on time than
i am
okay he found a good good sequence here
rook a6
yeah that was a bit unfortunate um
now i just have to protect and start
all over again okay we'll go king f7 the
bishop b4 is protected next i will go
rookie seven
if he trades rook i'm happy with that
since his rook was the active one
and then i'll bring bring my king around
and i should eventually win this game
okay um trade but also just working the
king up seems fine
king c4 now i think d4 is falling
and uh yeah bishop c3 seems cleanest
take on d4 next
and um two pawns up is um
at least one too much
uh yeah
wherever i can flag or
can win on the boards it's a
nice situation to be in okay uh good
game by my opponent
and i think uh also a very decent game
from
an instructional point of view uh
because it showed
the the value of
the pawn structure and that is
eventually what
decided this game